hello everybody in today's video I would
like to dedicate some time to career
opportunities for contract agents you
may know that the EU institutions offer
a variety of contracts you can work with
us as an EU official a civil servant
you can work with us as a trainee as a
second National expert as a temporary
agent and also as a contract agent
contract agents usually get an initial
contract of one to two years and these
contracts can be prolonged to a maximum
duration of six years in total
now you will also find terminology like
cast on our website cost stands for
contract agent selection tool so it
refers to exactly this the selection of
contract agents
and you may also find the terminology
cost permanent
permanent means that we have a list of
profiles available on our website which
for which you can permanently register
so you do not have to wait until we
publish a given profile they are
permanently available on our website and
you can register for one or more of
these profiles
currently we have a list of about 19
different profiles on offer
say you have for instance a degree in
informatics well then you could register
for the information and communication
technology profile
and why not also for the project and
program management profile so depending
on your degrees and expertise you can
register for one or more profiles
in the third column you see the grade
mentioned we have function groups we
call them FG FG goes from one to four
function group one and two relate to the
more executive tasks for the
non-graduate profiles
and functions group 3 and 4 relate to
more policy related work so The Graduate
profiles and on offer and in these
different profiles you may have
different function groups on offer
now let's have a look at how the
selection works
I said you can always register the
registration is always open so you do
not have to wait until we publish as I
said there is no deadline for applying
you register anytime even tonight if you
like so
once you have registered you basically
show your interest in working with UNC
social institutions
you are not automatically called for
being tested which is for instance the
case if you apply for a competition to
become a civil servant a permanent
official
if you apply for such a an opportunity
everybody who applies gets invited to
being tested with contract agents is
different you show your interest in
working with us by registering for one
of these profiles
and then the next step is
when an institution or any other
recruiting body has a vacancy they will
scan this list of candidates or
registered people and shortlist a number
of interesting profiles interesting in
the sense of could they match the
vacancy at stake
and the shortest people will be invited
by episode for being tested
abso will test your reasoning skills
verbal numerical and abstract reasoning
in any of the 24 languages and your
language wants so to speak when you
apply you have to indicate your
languages that you master for most of
you this language one will be your
mother tongue but it doesn't have to be
if you feel more confident in another
language it's up to you to choose any of
these 24 languages to cities tested
good to know is that we run all tests
remotely so you do not have to travel to
a test center to sit these tests you can
easily sit them from your home computer
in your own environment really
it will be of course a proctored
environment you will there will be an ID
check and you have to show that you are
alone in your room but apart from that
it's quite easy to set these tests from
home
when you are successful
you can be invited to an interview by a
recruiting body and this interview can
also involve an assessment of certain
competencies needed to fill the post at
stake the vacancy at stake
and if your interview is successful you
can be offered a contract and start
working as a contract agent
if the interview was not successful
your name stays in the database of the
profile of your cast list
and the good news then is that whenever
you would be shortlisted again in future
by another recruiting body for another
vacancy you do not have to reset your
tests the results of your tests stay
valid for the next 10 years
so once you are shortlisted again you
can go straight to the interview
and if successful you can be hired as a
contract agent
I hope this was clear if you have
questions please you can always
contact us through the web form
available on our website follow us on
social media as well where we keep you
updated on contract agent positions but
also other types of job vacancies and
offers that we that we publish so keep
in touch and thanks for your attention
for now bye bye